I also Gomez - welcome back to another
episode of Dark Souls 2
gonna try to not suck so much this
episode down the elevator baby hey I
don't look too bad actually I look like
[ __ ]
and yeah I whoa what is that a boss
fight no not a boss fight ah
oh it's a butthole I'm fighting a giant
button
oh god I make noises what's he working
it ah ah all right text what does he say
like a dream yeah that'll help the last
giant I don't want to kill him how does
it be you have to kill me
am I gonna fight the boss with a half
hell alright let's give this second try
baby god damn it so swagging seriously
this is like jb 2.0 one shot it
yeah they'll take a few a nice attack
but staff but staff whatsapp so many
butts that oh god I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm not dead
I should be dead I'm gonna go to space I
do that thing where you watch them no ha
but Sam he's pretty easy to hit at least
says this will probably take like 3
years time 200 job bloody head invest
aside it's fine not dead yet I should
have died there okay let me drink your
mom's urine what is he doing is he going
to sleep no oh god damn it what is that
that's cheating he ripped off his arm
that's cheating he's kidding
that's totally cheating nice ass by the
way so we meet again is he gonna take
his arm now the emo do the ass flat I
want to see your medulla Oh God
I got him sorry I'm sorry don't [ __ ]
one hit me oh god I'm dead [ __ ] your
medulla sucks
I press final chance let's [ __ ] do
this
oh [ __ ] that was so close
you're not as cool as you think you are
that's what elders told me thinking he's
way cooler than everybody else
oh god what is that what are you doing
don't do that oh god damn it
all right doing it PETA hand haha come
on
oh us I'm beautiful here ugly just deal
with that goddamn it cop more kawaii
that's right
haha that's awesome
first boss in pixels bet it so we got a
key does that go over here oh my god
what is this
a lot of people died here [ __ ] go yes
he's [ __ ] turtle you're my level now
[ __ ] dodging poke dodging poke and
that's how you Dark Souls baby all right
doing a lot better than last episode
that's for sure
oh [ __ ] more Turtles Oh at guys trying
to poop
hey guys swear to God if you poop on me
let's check the party in here ah ah
wrong room
wrong room sorry I don't know you were
masturbating I always like watch what no
more giant oh no oh is that guy
oh no not you I I know we're pissed from
before nice tits oh [ __ ] he got laser
eyes that's not fair
I'm screwed but he can fly how am I
gonna kill him ah [ __ ] I was hoping I
could get one attack on him but
apparently not oh my god
30 [ __ ] 30 how the hell I'm gonna
kill him look you can't even see what I
did there and that's that well that sure
was fun no really No
okay boss
bye-bye Sneed a couple of souls to buy a
[ __ ] club so I can spank that big
breasted man's ass is that too much
voice I don't think so
No
fine I don't mind spending [ __ ] hours
doing nothing and you're happy and you
know it clap your hands if you're happy
and you know it clap your hands if
you're happy and you know it why are you
[ __ ] dark so like I got my 90 souls
back that's great
about a give me my [ __ ] life back
literally okay let's let's think this
through
he may be badass and have giant tits but
we have our weights and scale who the
[ __ ] am I kidding we have [ __ ] oh god
jack Enderman these guys kill me
see that yeah I think I won that one
really fair fight fight the power row of
his power unicorn power I don't [ __ ]
it okay [ __ ] it okay he's mean I got a
clean Club you see this club it's gonna
go up your anus in a second that's oh
that is actually a lot better
do that again baby not hit me obviously
it's great when you can't even reach the
[ __ ] mouth
really no simply my first decent attempt
no no because I wanted to [ __ ] heels
for some [ __ ] reason why do I have to
hear why do I have to milk invisible
cows any jab now
um um um um uh Bubba dubstep man I'm not
sure if we can do this and they make me
depressed
Oh Shane oh oh what it hit me oh come on
I haven't even got him half health and
that's [ __ ] sad come here you little
[ __ ] that's right [ __ ] I managing to do
a guy for [ __ ] sake and God not now
please
double [ __ ] oh jesus oh Jesus he's nice
he's like I'm gonna let that [ __ ] left
well too bad I'm a [ __ ] Oh God I
never got this far before
not even close to this before and he
hasn't even touched me that's the thing
I did before
oh [ __ ] Oh
oh mama mia pizzeria come on come on
walk walk walk walk walk walk way Oh oh
[ __ ] alright come on
I'm gonna cry I'm gonna [ __ ] cry here
we go
three more attacks MTV should be down
I'm just gonna be patient oh [ __ ] me oh
[ __ ]
one more one more
Oh forward and slap no
easy